if you recall on Monday we had a look at
how many tree graphs again we looked at
six we start with sine cos and tan and
then what can I do with those three to
get to the other three I so I took the
reciprocals of each of them I'll just be
careful with that word inverse it
actually needs something very specific
in the extension one cost which will get
up to Maine up which we were not doing
on Monday on Monday we're looking at
their it's difficult functions so just
to recall quickly you've got sign you've
got cause you've got tan what's the
reciprocal of sine again you were
whatever sign is what time circuits fun
gets special name that we give it is per
sec the special name further terminal
cause is sick now by the way I've been
thinking about this do you remember why
sign is called sign do you know what
it's actually finding it to what we're
looking at this right basically it's
curved sign is short for sinusoidal wave
which means a curvy wait what about
cosine Y screw high school buddies
because it's because a closed sensible
compliment right so sine and cosine by
that 90 degree shift now that's as far
as I have gone it explains the days of
any of these things right I wonder if
you have any concept at all as to why
tan is cold tape zeros short for tangent
right just like well what it takes them
to do it anything right know either of
the definitions you know for tan at the
moment
which are opposite by adjacent or sign
of the cause neither of them shed any
real light on what it has agents doing
dangerous I've been sort of
contemplating how far to go before I
actually show you why they are all
caught what they are because kind of we
survived all the way to the end of your
own 11:12 even do some University than
us and don't really know why they call
what they are but I'm just curious about
to kind of you drive you crazy
so we'll see how we go for time over the
next couple of weeks but right now what
we're going to do is take these six
grams and we're going to modify them in
different ways we haven't looked at
beyond what I call the vanilla basic
unmodified tree grass on Monday so I
want to think and I wonder if it can
help me here you should be able to name
most if not all of these what ways can
we take say let's just start with sign
okay can you take sign and actually that
should be fine I've got the wrong number
cause I'll leave the fifth one too late
if it's harder what are the ways in
which you can change the appearance of
and the behavior of a trick graph any
suggestions what could we do it again
didn't give me one I said it again okay
so if we think about what sign X looks
like and maybe actually if you could
draw for me just a small version of
sonics up in the top corner of your page
but these suggestions that we throw it a
number in there like two now this is
specific where would you like me to put
the number in front of where in front of
the X which I've been put in front of
the X so let's consider I'll put it just
leave it like a little dot point if I
can see that y equals sine two x okay so
a comes out let's do one thing at a time
is it
good morning mr. popular it is if we
think about why cosine 2x how is this
thing different
okay well what I want you to do is just
get your calculator out let's just
experiment a little bit so we can set
for ourselves this is one of many ways
but it's gonna clear everything good so
I hope you know this graph well enough
to know is the regular sine X graph what
all of the numbers are that are
important to the sign extra okay if
that's just regular sine X up there how
far am i drawing what don't wait oh my
god
not to 360 right so therefore you know
there's your ending 360 which means
halfway is 180 which means you've got
that top at the bottom remember I gave
those specific names I called them I
call this facility spots
I call them turning points because the
graph literally goes up and then it
turns around because down and vice versa
now we also know the values where those
happen right that's going to be 90 and
270 great yes
so you should be expected if for example
you punched in the sine of 90 degrees
off of that graph you should expect a
particular number back and when you
punch it in just go ahead do it
I hope it can pose to you what you were
expecting sine 90 equals 1/4 to be as
fundamental a fact at your brain as you
know after a comes being after become cm
etc okay it's a fundamental fat don't
want to have to think about that kind of
thing you want it to be fluently you
might okay here's what we're going to do
we're going to experiment with this guy
a little bit okay so instead of having
sine 90 in my calculator what I'm gonna
do is I'm gonna say sine 2 and then I'm
going to supply an angle okay now
because we just did sign 19 right I
could say sine of two times 45 and that
is also 90 right so when you hit equals
it's applied back to you one
unsurprisingly
right except I didn't have to put in x
equals maybe I put in x equals 45 right
does that make sense
in other words this Sun is one which is
the highest that this factor is going to
go this turning point
it happens earlier does that make sense
behind it on the normal graph it takes
me all the way from zero all the way up
to ninety degrees to get to that high
point but this guy gets there faster I
really have to go from 0 up to 45 and
I'm already there at 1
does that make sense ok so you can keep
on putting a few more values in for
example if you go sign and then you say
2 times nightly you should be able to
predict before you hit equals what that
is going to say to you because you know
what the original graph looks like right
so when you hit equals it gives you 0
because sine of June 8 is 0 but I didn't
have to put in x equals 180 yet there I
really had to put it
x equals 90 right so in order to go up
and down the normal sine graph takes a
hundred and eighty degrees to do that
but this guy gets there twice as fast
does that make sense that's kind of what
this guy is doing right that to X means
get there do everything twice as quickly
okay so what do we call this in what way
maybe you want to draw underneath here
now a little same axis D that I get to
everything twice as quickly if I draw
for norton 360 I get my first copy not
from up to 360 but twice as fast from
not to what's halfway it's 180 right so
it's taken me half the time to get a
full copy of the sine wave
but if I do know from naught to 360 I'm
going to draw a little further because
if I'm going twice as fast then I'm
going to get two copies does that make
sense
what do we call this feature what is it
that geometrically we changed about this
you can say either two ways I have a
stock even people signing over then you
could either say I've changed the
frequency of the graph which in other
words is saying oh this is more frequent
now right it's happening faster or you
can say what's the flip side of it what
else do we call this starts with the
pink we also call this third period
right now these are not the same idea
these two things are not synonymous with
each other this year zone this is really
describing this isn't bad but period
says well how long does it take for you
to get a full copy right the period is
now hard the frequency has doubled okay
so the way I think about this and maybe
you want to even write it with each side
2x when you see two what that means is
two full copies of the graph in your
regular this is X in your regular domain
which is not a physics okay so the
period used to be 360 degrees now it's a
hundred and eighty okay sometimes you'll
see the formula that the period is 360
degrees divided by in you'll see that in
textbooks sometimes okay do you see what
they're doing there they say this is in
the number attached X coefficient okay
if you want to find it at the period
you're just going 360 divided by two
which is 180 okay that works
I don't like it as much I find this more
intuitive because you don't accidentally
do it backwards for example if we now
put underneath here rather than y equals
sine 2x how about y equals sine of say X
on 2002
this again is going to change the
frequency or period to make it a little
clearer let me write it like this I know
there's not much change but it makes it
a little more obvious what's going on if
sine 2x has two full copies of the graph
for not to 360 then how many full copies
of the graph do you expect this to have
four not to 360 it's up half of a full
copy so this is the are but down that
you're supposed to get one half you draw
you stop a little stare axes underneath
here instead of going all the way up and
they're dead and then back to the
beginning
this guy doesn't do it fast enough he
goes half the speed so excuse me from
naught to 360 you're just gonna get that
there's 360 where's the turn T 20 up and
down 180 degrees halfway so we're done
does that make sense so this is a just
frequency or period